what is this why do i voice your leader
what is this hell is that what is all of
this I'm starting to questioning life
and what Jenny fire Jana fire I am
disappointed what are you doing that my
name and welcome to if you're not
familiar with Fridays with PewDiePie
it's basically my weekly check-in witty
brows you know talk about life the bro
army my subscribers have grown a lot
late I thought why not make these
Fridays with PewDiePie a little bit
different a little bit more a connection
between you and I so I'm actually gonna
answer a couple of questions about
myself I read most of the comments or if
you want to you can of course and answer
them as well I mean why not I'm really
interested to see who actually watching
my videos first off though I have some
news about the new amnesia game the new
title is amnesia a machine for pigs
piggies bump
pig is making a comeback I just hope
Stephano will be in it as far as you
know you should all the sources said the
game would not be as scary but I think
they're just trying to trick us it will
be scary for [ __ ] still on my schnitzel
another new that I have to say before we
started stuff I'm launching a new site
it's purified net this time hey Bert but
it sounded like I was really awkward
this time it's a really cool site we got
the best forum thing leading like
building it's a great way for me to
communicate with you Bruce as well and
you know Facebook Twitter contact email
I got so many things I just it would be
nice to have everything in one place
first question is what's your name I
think the audios know it already it's
not really a secret it says even says in
my face
good thing but my name my full name is
Felix Arvid Ulf what's your name
you're like Dora the Explorer what's
your name I want to hear it
I've been getting a ton of mess like
text messages and phone calls from you
bros I had to change a number and made
it secret because I don't know it was
it's cool to talk to you bros but like
most of it would just like prank calls
like someone calls and then I'm like
Hello would be like I don't answer as
PewDiePie and then just hang it and they
hang up so I I don't know it was cool
when people like eh Peter pie but I'm
sorry I can't do that anymore and
whoever's still calling you're calling
my dad by the way and he's pissed stop
doing that stop trying to call me I'm
sorry how old are you I'm 22 years old
born 1989 the 24th why do you live well
right now I live a bit outside
Gothenburg which is the best rating in
do not know it's not good it's in Sweden
I live here with my girlfriend and yeah
I guess that's it maybe I make a tour of
our apartment one day but now now ain't
got no time what's your favorite
activity make a guess what do you think
my favorite activity is to play video
games I guess it's always been my
favorite something that I love doing and
I know I will always do as well my
current position that's kind of I don't
know why I guess making YouTube videos
it's pretty much my job right now to
make these videos hey I couldn't be
happier about having this as my job I
used to have the shittiest job you bros
so when I realized I could quit that job
to just make youtube videos I can't
remember the last time I was so happy I
used to study industrial economics at
the University which is great like
education and like I dropped that
because I hated it and then I started
doing more of these YouTube videos and
that's like what I actually love to do
so ever since I've done that things have
really gone my way like met my
girlfriend half a year ago well before
that I don't know my life has definitely
changed a lot since the last year at
least and I I don't think I've ever been
this happy in my life so word of advice
follow your heart and I think everything
will work out eventually I hope I hope I
don't mess up your life here yeah I
don't know if there's anything else you
want to ask me feel free to do it in the
comment I haven't selected a winner yet
for the last week so I'll just put an
annotation anyway I thought this week we
can give away why should I give away in
which game darkness - I haven't played
the game it looks awesome made by
Swedish nerds
I mean Swedish developers if you want to
win all you have to do is leave a
comment about and whatever but don't say
how much you want the game like last
time I just got a bunch of requests
everywhere I want the game so bad
my brother has cancer in his toe I can't
really know for sure if that's true or
not this feels really weird just write a
comment about whatever and I'll select
the winner yeah that's totally sounded
like an [ __ ] that I'm sorry this face
is amazing
that's pretty much it for this week's
bad that's not a voice crack anyway
knows some DJ in the background so yeah
stay awesome bros I couldn't be happier
about having such an awesome fanbase
you are the most awesome fan base on
year 2 so that's why I'm gonna punish
you and I'm just kidding I would never
punch just a little slack
sometimes you deserve it a little sappy
but that's the only because I love you
so yeah I'm sorry well then is with the
brofist in three all right you ready I
don't see no bro fridge that are there
we go
all right one two three
[Music]
you
[Music]
all right we got done